one of the things i've started to
realize is that it's much easier doing
this when you have color
photos gosh that's very diverse bunch
isn't
it thank you i'm whether it's a bit too
diverse okay so what i've done
here is assimilate all the data from the
program
along with tuva's trace matches and
combine that with an algorithm that
basically mimics my own gut instincts
anyway taking all of that into account
these are our top
six suspects you know two of these are
the same person
yeah it was a test you passed uh anyone
have a preference as to which
photo we use maybe the one where he's
smiling i know you shouldn't say it but
i always think it must be quite
stressful being a terrorist
yeah okay oh god it's not i'm thinking
from the doritos commercial
you know what i mean so no we'd probably
have to go through his agent anyway
so who exactly are we looking at here
then right so
my money is on abdullah
uh blah blah blah and he's a resident in
the uk
yeah i guess as much as joseph is
resident in the uk
i am resident in the uk so sorry did you
work for the nhs as well though
yes he's a licensed chiropractor which
as we all know is not a real thing so
immediately i was like
why why what about jenny taylor
she worked for the nhs for 20 years
was made redundant in 2017 after the
cuts
the following year she lost her husband
when he was accidentally prescribed the
wrong medication for eczema oh gosh
plus she has a phd in computer science
and hasn't been seen for the last
three weeks well
yeah i don't know i keep being drawn
back to
abdullah for some reason isn't that faro
i don't know it depends what you just
said that is fruit but it won't be him
he sadly blew his brains out in prison
in 2014.
right did he die okay so this is great
we're slowly narrowing it down to
abdullah
who is margaret well i thought it could
be her too
but she's been sectioned what like cut
up into pieces
uh no i'm committed even better bye-bye
maggie
so i guess i was right abdullah's our
guy but he doesn't have
quite as strong a motive as jenny
yeah but look at him does he really need
one yeah but motive is your thing right
i mean it's what you've been saying it's
all about motive
wait a minute are you guys honestly
telling me that behind the face
of this sweet respectable white lady
is the monster we're looking for jesus
oh my god
where did she come in
please tell me this isn't what it looks
like why what does it look like
that you've undermined my authority
putting your own ego ahead of gchq
procedure
to pursue an agenda fueled by ignorance
and racial prejudice
maybe you're the racist for assuming i'm
racist
when jenny here clearly has the
requisite
background education and motive to hack
the nhs shame on you chris
and you're welcome
[Music]
follow me chop chop
you